une balance une arnaque dans laquelle
vous avez en fumée le fisc depuis 2 500
patates en moins de quatre mois
[Musique]
pour cela vous avez utilisé le fric dans
voyous notoires qui aujourd'hui met à la
mode
moi quoi je devrais être protégé comme
ça en fermant les yeux sur toute cette
merde
bon si je vous file se remettre tout de
suite là juste pour des placements
[Musique]
as tu verras ajouté tentative de
corruption de fonctionnaires ça pourrait
faire une addition un peu l'autre point
a pu choquer je me connais la chanson tu
crois pas 10 6 mois sera moins lourd qui
nous enveloppe que je vous donnerai si
vous travaillez pour moi alors la
financière et sur votre cul tombe au
père c'est lui qui vous a balancé